in the before times everyone stayed here
in the pocket
quarterbacks were slow respected and
allowed to be wrong every now and then
dang another pick you got plenty hex the
average qb has 2.7 seconds in the pocket
rushers run don't you get it we
can't
sam you know i'm a cornfed passer you
ever think there's a world outside this
here pocket if i think about my
circumstances i cry
mom can't need perv oh no my ghost
vision sixth sense
warn the guards you know a real good
show would be about us offensive line
yes the problem is
nobody notices when we don't let people
in yeah your mom and dad i'm not
enjoying camp anymore
pick me up i have a big lead so i'm
probably not going to make it
find the disciples of vic all right bye
y'all
i'm sweating more than a linebacker
sunday morning service
my leg guns are as good as my top on the
whole world is a pocket to me
your family thanks running back
for us still
[Music]
i'm more tired and butter on a city
slicker biscuit sheesh
i'm as tired as a hard working double
chef phew
i'm more tired than a coyote at a
carnival whew i'm more tired than a
gator on a roller coaster
i'm more tired of the banjo i want to
buy you i ran faster one left gridiron
heist car too